alors tania je vais laisser tomber le
vous parce que ce soir c'était ton
dernier cinq minutes tu nous qui disent
nous quitte pour un an théoriquement
parce que tu as deux gros projets de
beaux projets à réaliser et tu vas aller
loin pour le faire oui exactement alors
dans la prochaine année 2016 sera
consacré un projet en fait d'un domaine
que j'aime beaucoup dany vinet réalise
un film la suite de blade runner
alors je vais l'accompagner sur le
plateau travailler avec lui alors pour
la logistique là ce sera une toute
nouvelle aventure
et moi je tiens mon retour à te dire
merci parce que j'ai adoré faire ces
cinq minutes et je remercie je vous
remercie vous je remercie les artistes
avec pour leur générosité je remercie
aussi public qui ont beaucoup réagit qui
m'ont beaucoup écrit et je vous voyez
mon expérience si serré depuis le début
de la journée alors merci de finir en
beauté
là on est triste de voir partir mais
enfin je dois dire que c'est une
expérience j'en suis certaine
extraordinaire tu pouvais pas passer à
côté de ce nom ça va t'amener ailleurs
et puis au nom de toute l'équipe tania
merci parce que c'est un gros morceau du
vendredi soir du vendredi soir qui part
avec toi même et là on va revoir et
merci à tout le monde à radio canada je
salue